oh hi i'm starting today detective
santiago oh
detective peralta welcome aboard i'm
hearing wedding bells
hi detective boyle
[Music]
[Applause]
amy santiago you have made me the
happiest man on earth
i spent one whole dollar on this ring
will you go on the worst date ever with
me
you have to say yes yes she said yes
she said yes
[Music]
jake you know why little boys pull
little girls pigtails on playgrounds
cause they're so easy to grab they're
just begging to be pulled because they
like the girls and that's the only way
they know how to get their attention
what are you saying all of this season
this elaborate date
somewhere down deep you like aiming like
like you're like
okay that's straight up insanity how
much did you spend on tonight
fourteen hundred dollars but all of it's
on credit cards so it's like five
dollars a month for the next two
thousand years i do not like amy
you're putting a lot of effort into a
joke why don't you just sit down and
have a real conversation with her uh
excuse me everyone
santiago and i will be performing the
steerage jig from the film titanic
which we have prepared for in no way
shape or form
romantic now embarrassing milady
do this mini hate your guts channel that
passion into the dance
only if you throw it ready ready
nice ready uh-huh
what are you doing you're trying to
catch it in your nose
i got it i got it i got it huh it's hulk
keep practicing okay
peralta oh good news peralta i found
someone from the night shift to relieve
you on your stakeout oh
still make times square um
you know captain hold off on the relief
team we're already here
plus i'm curious to see what happens
okay it's your call
what do you hold on just checking in how
you doing any progress
yep watch
the key is volume i see that all right
look the reason that i didn't want to
work with you is
should i do this in an accent so that i
can undercut some of the awkwardness i'm
feeling
no good call remember when you told me
that you didn't want to date cops
that really bummed me out man jamaican
yeah it was a bad choice i'm much better
at german all right fine i was
kind of thinking about asking you out oh
okay but i know that that's not what you
want and i totally get it i think it
just took me a while to totally totally
get it and now i totally get it
jake this is weird the whole point of me
not dating cops is so it wouldn't be
weird at work
okay so let's just make it not weird
right this is a case
we work cases together all the time and
we're really good at it so
you know we're professionals that's all
i want for us to be professional
we're in agreement it will be good and
professional
all right you have a visual one the
hostess stand
table for two please i'm so sorry
there's nothing available we're totally
booked up
oh no that's horrible tonight's a really
important night for us johnny and i just
got engaged and
this is where our first date was oh yeah
it would mean so much to dora and me
i would have made a reservation but i
didn't know if she was gonna say yes
oh i love how nervous you were you
little goose
you were just so sweet together you know
i'm sure i can find room for two young
lovers
yeah we are lovers together
in bed okay
[Music]
hey seriously we're cool right yeah
totally we're fine
okay gosh you know i'm actually a little
bit hungry i never ended up eating at
that dumb fancy restaurant
know what i'm getting on my way home
yeah you're gonna go to the polish place
and get pierogies potato pancakes and a
cup of hot chocolate
that's exactly what i'm gonna get i will
be having pizza
two slices of meat supreme from tony
served display temperature
meat supreme is a million red flags and
eating it cold is just insane
no it's not cold it's display
temperature there's a difference amy no
jake he's looking at us well this is
happening huh
[Music]
nypd's nypd we are police colleagues
you're under arrest
this is a work event this whole night
was really weird i know
i just uh i want everything to go back
how it was
you know it's so awkward yeah you're
right we shouldn't date cops
it's we're a great team we work great
together
i don't want to mess that up yeah i
don't want everything to change
yeah me neither okay then that's that
detective peralta detective santiago
see you around the precinct yep
tall butt listen i know you said you
don't want to date cops
but i really like you
i like you too good but what if we start
dating
and it makes things weird at work so
let's just keep it light and breezy
see where it goes totally yeah so
how do we keep it light and breezy i
know
a comprehensive set of rules how am i
attracted to you doesn't matter i am go
rule one let's not tell anyone so we can
figure out what this is first
smort rule number two let's not put
labels on it we're not boyfriend and
girlfriend we're just
mermseep and jinglebin great rule number
three
let's not have sex right away
no doubt no doubt no doubt no doubt good
rule no sex good rule
so should we go out tonight yeah totally
maybe eight maybe nine doesn't matter
we're light and breezy totally
light and breezy briefing room
five minutes wow very chill
here we are officially on a date
romantical date yes we are no longer
just colleagues
dating you got a haircut
it looks nice oh thanks you also got a
haircut
at some point in your life i'm sure
that's not your baby hair that would be
crazy right
but uh yeah you look very nice domo
arigato
do you speak japanese no oh
ah sorry i think you're feeling a little
awkward
yeah me too how do we make it not weird
i know let's just get super drunk yes
great idea pardon me ma'am could you
please bring us four kamikaze shots
and four for me as well ah i like your
style see
we can do this we're back on track we're
keeping it light
and breezy so
we broke a rule yeah i hope it wasn't a
mistake
hope it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape title of our sex tape
sorry sorry that's okay i
was home and i really wanted to talk to
someone about us
and dozerman and about hope being gone
and then i realized
that the only person i want to talk
about that stuff with is you
so screw just being colleagues
and screw light and breezy right
definitely guys we did it
we really did it oh charles is here
big time
thank you for doing this i love you
noice smart
[Music]
i love you too
[Music]
also i think this is definitely a dance
class for widows
no i don't think so no now turn to your
partner and tell them how your spouse
died
yeah we should get out of here are you
sure yes okay i'm an amazing human slash
genius yeah although
you might want to read the inscription
on that they're belt why
oh no what does it say amy santiago will
you marry me
surprise
i'm so confused i don't know what's
happening right now i'm so confused i
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape
oh my god i'm shaking i'm definitely
gonna cry
title of your sex tape wait is this
really happening
is this part of the heist if this is
part of the heist i will dump you so
hard
no please look it's really happening
okay it's not part of the heist i love
how beautiful you are
i love your face and i love your butt i
should have written this down first no
no it's okay
go on i love how much you pretend to
like die hard
i like the second one you don't have to
okay yeah you're
kind and you're funny and you're the
best person i know and
the best detective
also for reals i love your butt i love
yours too gross
amy santiago will you marry me
jake peralta i will marry you
i love you so much hey jerkos this
little [ __ ] escapes so that ought to
teach did you just mm-hmm
and did you say mm-hmm
you